hi i'm christine goodwin on this episode
of the fox news rundown
the latest national polls suggest
president trump
is still trailing democratic
presidential nominee joe biden
but with 60 days until the election is
the margin tightening
trump campaign national press secretary
hogan gidley discusses the 2020 race
polls and claims by the biden campaign
that president trump is fanning the
flames of america's civil unrest
and the coronavirus pandemic halting tv
and film productions around the world
for months affecting talent on and off
the screen
fox news radio's entertainment reporter
michelle palino
details how theaters and studios are
trying to stay afloat
and whether their comeback will have a
hollywood ending
plus fox nation host tammy bruce has
commentary on house speaker nancy
pelosi's controversial trip
to a california hair salon the fox news
rundown is a daily news podcast where we
take a deeper look at the stories
important to you
you can subscribe on your favorite
podcast player
by going to foxnewspodcast.com
i'm bill hemmer i'm janis dean i'm juan
williams and this is the fox news
rundown
friday september 4th 2020 i'm jessica
rosenthal
new polling data is out as both the
president and his rival spent time on
the road this week in key
swing states the discussion focusing on
police
violence and protests they're saying if
he comes in it's fascist and then when
the city burns to the ground
they point to donald trump and say it's
his fault he can't have it both ways
i'm chris foster more movie theaters
closed because of the coronavirus
outbreak are back open this weekend
movie theaters are adopting a cinema
safe
protocol that's what they're calling it
it basically means that they're going to
separate people by parties
and i'm tammy bruce i've got the final
word on the fox news rundown
[Music]
both president trump and former vice
president joe biden visited kenosha
wisconsin this week
while trump met with members of law
enforcement and business owners in the
town that was badly damaged by rioting
former vice president biden met with
jacob blake's family as well
blake was shot in the back by police he
is alive but his family
said he was paralyzed and his shooting
prompted the protests
and rioting which biden addressed with
community members
protesting his protest my buddy john
lewis used to say
but none of it justifies looting burning
or anything else he said as president he
would have a
national commission on policing out of
the white house because a significant
portion of the police
are decent people but no one there's a
lot of bad folks in every organization
there's not a whole lot of people who
want to speak up
be the odd man out or odd woman out no
matter what outfit you work with he told
them about his conversation with blake's
family and jacob himself over the phone
who
he says was out of the icu he talked
about how
nothing was going to defeat him
how whether he walked again or not he
was not going to give up
biden says they prayed with the family
and that blake's mother said she prayed
for her son
but also for the officer who shot her
son biden said the president only wants
to talk about law and order but
not covet because of the number of
people who've died and the businesses
that have closed
and that win or lose he will go down
fighting for racial equality and
equity across the board but the
country's ready
and if they're not it doesn't matter
because there's certain things i ain't
going to change
there's certain things worth losing over
and this is something worth losing over
we have to but we're not going to lose
now the president who'd been to kenosha
earlier in the week
visited pennsylvania thursday rallying
supporters in an airport hangar in
latrobe i will keep you jobs in america
and i'll bring
rioters looters violent extremists
anarchists we will bring them to justice
that's what we're doing right now
pennsylvania is one place where polling
data has shifted the latest monmouth
poll out this week found a statistical
tie
with president trump having gained nine
points trailing biden by just
four now the latest fox news poll showed
biden leading in key swing states
by eight points in wisconsin nine in
arizona and four in north carolina
we're in a good in good shape here at
the campaign our internal polls have us
a head tied or within striking distance
of all the states needed to win this
election hogan gidley is a trump
campaign spokesman
and get the president four more years
giving the american people
peace and prosperity again and we're
really excited about where we are
and the convention was a big big reason
for that things started to turn
slightly before when when the american
people got a chance to see democrats
for four days basically saying that
america is inherently evil
that we are the cause of all the world's
problems and we just take a different
tact we used real americans um
across this country who pointed to the
fact that they received opportunities
in america that they would never receive
anywhere else on the planet
and how this president's policies made
their lives better regardless of race
religion color or creed and that's gone
a long way to to remind the american
people
not just all that the president has been
able to accomplish because lord knows
during the democrat convention they
didn't say a word about biden's
accomplishments
or his socialist agenda because they
didn't want that out in public
but it reminded the american people just
how high we can be
as a nation when you have a party in
control that loves
the nation and that's the republicans
and that's donald trump
well what do you make then of the um the
numbers raised
by the dnc and the biden campaign 364
million for the month of august and
they're claiming that 1.5
million new donors have participated
in recently if people were turned off by
the democrats convention um you know
what do you make of these new numbers
well look go into the numbers a little
bit deeper what you're going to see is
we have
vastly outpaced democrats in voter
registration so you can give it to a
campaign all you want to it doesn't
necessarily mean
you're going to vote but also remember
we've been building an
organization on the ground in these
states 70
million voter contacts since covet
started
uh to shut down the country in march um
more than a million people every single
month we reach
directly via door knocks and other
things so you can't backfill
how important it is to have a ground
game and an apparatus
to make sure people are mobilized and
ready to get out
to vote let's not also forget
that it's this president and our social
media pages that have more than a
billion views across our platforms
because people are excited
and enthusiastic about where the
country's going and the leadership at
the top with the president
in the white house so you can't go back
and look and say well they also got a a
presidential
excuse me a vice presidential nominee in
that time in kamala harris
granted she's the most socialist leftist
they've ever received even further
to the left than bernie sanders via via
gov track voting
poll statistics but um you know that
that's something they haven't received
yet so it's all
new for them we've already we've been
there and done that
at this at this point in time so we're
breaking records every month with the
money we're raising
it's just democrats haven't had a
nominee or vice president
up until this point in time hogan
thursday mr biden met with jacob blake's
family when he went to kenosha wisconsin
the president as we know did not but he
did meet with law enforcement and
business owners when he went
do those kinds of optics matter the
president not meeting with the blake
family
i think it matters greatly i think it
matters the american people
which president they know would be on
the side of law enforcement
be on the side of making sure our
american communities are safe
and secure that's obviously donald trump
he increased
funding to to the brave men and women at
the local level
that are on the front lines those police
officers out there
by billions of dollars over what joe
biden and his administration did when in
fact they
cut funding to cops at the local level
um not to mention the fact
four days of that convention the
democrats put on a democrat convention
democrat-controlled cities all burning
in in chaos and they didn't say
a single word about it in fact joe biden
still called them peaceful
still blame the police for the violence
inciting violence i think is the word
he actually he actually used and when
you compare and contrast that for what
we said
that those on the front lines should be
praised those on the front lines
should be allowed to do their jobs and
protect the american people
these democratic governors and mayors
are bragging about
the fact that they're not allowing
federal assets to come in
and solve the problem where we've sent
federal assets in this president has
done so
you've seen a drop in the violence
you've seen an end to the looting and
the rioting
but these these democrat governors and
mayors are trying to have it both ways
they are saying that the president comes
in to help
it's fascist well first of all it's not
if they're asked to come in it's
completely fine with the constitution he
could even use the insurrection act
but they're saying if he comes in it's
fascist and then when the city burns to
the ground
they point to donald trump and say it's
his fault you can't have it both ways
the president's offering to fix the
problem you're bragging about saying no
we're going to let the cities burn
and i think the american people
understand that so these images you see
out of a place like kenosha because
so much of this was occurring in like
major metropolitan areas
now it's in the heartland of this
country and you're seeing
this death and destruction this this
these assaults on american citizens
innocent americans just defending
themselves
that's a serious um issue in this
country and it's obvious where we stand
it's on the side of the american people
and on the law-abiding citizens of this
country and law enforcement
joe biden does well let me ask you about
that because we
got more and we got let me let me just
point out this one last thing
he's yet to condemn blm he hasn't
condemned antifa
and he sure hasn't said anything about
defund the police except that he's for
it
so the fact is he's on the wrong side of
these issues and the american people
know it
well and i want to ask you about that
because we have heard more from biden
uh this past week about how he
essentially plans to defend himself and
criticize the president we heard him
look into the camera and say do i really
seem like a radical socialist
he did say that looting and writing or
not protesting and that people should be
prosecuted
he also wrote in a june op-ed that not
only should police not be defunded
they should be given millions more
dollars
so that they can implement certain
reforms like buying body cameras
i i have a feeling over the next couple
of months vines gonna
continue to reiterate that and repeat
those kinds of words what do you say to
that
too little too late and i don't believe
him when he says it he didn't do it when
he had the had the chance to do it with
50 years in elected office and there's a
reason
these police unions are coming out in
support of president trump and not
joe biden who they used to support in
the past because they know
president trump has their back he has
from day one he will for the next four
years
as well as far as coming out and and
condemning violence
notice as i said he didn't get specific
and talk about the people who are
actually
committing the violence um and he also
said
in that committing violence he said
really the police are stoking the hatred
here it's the police's fault
so he's blaming the police for something
that criminals are doing
and you don't have to guess how this
looks when we're talking about funding
look at his campaign look at his vice
presidential pick the president
increased funding to cops
period end of story joe biden uh excuse
me when the president went to wisconsin
he also gave a million dollars to the
police force in kenosha
to try and help them with the assets
they needed gave four million dollars to
the businesses that have been destroyed
by this lawless behavior joe biden in
his campaign
decided they'd give money to people
who've been arrested
for destroying the businesses the very
ones who got
caught sending fires to churches setting
fires to federal buildings defacing
property
uh beating up innocent americans those
people
were taken to jail and joe biden
democrat
and kamala harris all decided to put
money into a fund
that would get those people out of jail
so their priorities are much
different and so while we have this
conversation now
going into the election it's going to be
really difficult for joe biden to claim
the mantle of law and order when he
ignored it for 90 days
and blamed the police for that
for that criminal behavior tell me um
the president was in
north carolina and he made some comments
that some people
felt it felt like he was saying that you
should go vote twice send in your ballot
early then go and vote if it hasn't been
tabulated then vote
i think um on thursday white house
spokeswoman kelly mcinney and even the
president himself through
tweets uh you know are clarifying that
he means you know
go to check to see if your mailing vote
counted and if it wasn't
then vote but but that would still
technically be voting
twice wouldn't it even if your initial
vote didn't count like how
how's this supposed to work well it's
funny the democrats are all outraged
about this now because
for for the last several weeks we've
been talking about the dangers of
universal mail and voting and the
potential for fraud
and abuse and double voting and now
they're like
and they were saying at the time no no
no that never happened that could never
happen the system is flawless
and then the president makes that
comment and they're all like whoa whoa
you can't double vote
that if they're so confident in the
system what are they worried about
the fact is the president was not saying
to vote twice
everyone knows that it's just another
trope that democrats try to use
to hurt the president of the united
states but
what they also have been caught in here
is the fact that
this universal mail-in voting system
they are pushing is
is is so problematic and will
so greatly damage uh this country's
you know voting system this electoral
process
when you try to change the way this
country votes
weeks before an election that is
all types of dangerous and the american
people are just now figuring out
what we've been saying is absolutely
accurate when you can
move the deadline for voting which
democrats are trying to do
in 10 states to allow votes to be
counted
after election day it's going to be a
serious problem
hogan gidley thank you so much for your
time thanks so much
have a great day
this is tammy bruce with your fox news
commentary coming up
like a lot of things because of the
coronavirus pandemic the summer movie
season didn't happen this year
a couple new movies came out in theaters
last month most have gone straight to
streaming in people's homes on services
like netflix hulu or amazon
or as a video on demand rental like what
orion pictures did with the 80s movie
sequel bill and ted face the music
take it from ourselves but isn't that
stealing
two big budget movies come out this
weekend one straight to subscribers
homes not theaters
warner brothers pictures is betting
people will come out to see theirs on
the big screen
uh tenant christopher nolan's time
bending sci-fi epic which
stars john david washington is set to
do big business at the box office fox
news radio entertainment reporter
michelle palino the national association
of theater owners are looking at this
film
to bring people back to the movies
so this is a very big deal it did bang a
business
overseas uh now overseas is is not
having the problems that we are
uh with closed theaters and you know
have the
theaters closed um but it still
did very well and so far
movies aren't doing well despite the
coronavirus pandemic
there's been a couple new releases in
the last couple of weeks there was an
x-men movie called new mutants there was
some very well good you know russell
crowe
i heard the movie wasn't so unhinged and
i heard the movies weren't particularly
good but people
this that may prove the point that
people just want to go back to the
movies
it did prove a point it did prove a
point uh box office
uh well while unhinged made four million
now it doesn't seem like a lot to you
but there's six thousand theaters movie
theaters
in the country only one third of those
theaters
were opened and again
spaced seating all the
protocols for coronavirus are in place
and they still did good numbers so
they're looking at
everything uh and and they've set
protocols safe protocols
for the movie business moving forward so
what's going on in theaters now it's
what is it 25 50
capacity you can only sit with your
little party
that's exactly how they're doing it
movie theaters are adopting a
cinema safe protocol that's what they're
calling it
and it basically means that they're
going to separate people by parties
even if you know if you're a single
person you will have two seats
around you if you're a group of five at
the same thing you will have two to four
seats around you where you can sit with
your party
in a cinema and feel safe and it's masks
on
unless you're eating or drinking right
that's correct so
on the other end of things disney
has a big movie that was supposed to
come out earlier in the summer called
mulan
a live action remake of the cartoon i
will briana
leading a man's army
it is my duty to fight for the kingdom
and they're now pushing that to its
disney plus streaming service
instead of putting it in theaters it's
an interesting test case the way it's
going to work
is that if you have disney plus you have
to have disney plus and then you pay an
extra 30 bucks on top of that to have
mulan for as long as your subscriptions
active huh
you're right this is an interesting test
case
uh i do not think this is the wave of
the future
i do not at all based on the numbers
that are coming out
and we'll see some big numbers i believe
uh from tenet this weekend
that i've seen with the new mutants and
with unhinged
and speaking with movie theaters and
comscores box office analysts
uh all uh
all roads are leading to people still
want to go out to the movies
people still love the community
aspect of seeing a movie in a theater
with other people despite the protocols
in place the mulan thing
i mean that's 29.99 you can say geez
that's a lot of money but it's still a
lot cheaper than taking
you know your family with kids to them
to the actual movies
and um you can watch it over and over
again which sometimes kids want to do
but you said you got an early look at it
and it's just not the same
it's not the same and there are some
great action scenes in this
great fight scenes in this film
that i was surprised that
i was not moved and i know i would be
moved in a theater
these are big powerful uh
war scenes in mulan if you've seen the
animated version you know what i'm
talking about
uh great movie scenes did not it fell
flat for me watching it on my computer
some things are probably going to work
better than others i mean i wonder if
this
could hurt even more small little dramas
where it may be the experience of
watching it at home isn't
that diminished as opposed to watching a
comedy where you're in a room laughing
with a bunch of people or a horror movie
where you're scared with a bunch of
people or
just something that you want to see on a
really really big screen i wonder if
it's those little
dramas that get heard huh
i think it's those little dramas that
are going to end up
on uh our streaming services that's what
i mean
yeah i i think i don't think they're
going to get
hurt i think they'll work out a way
financially
to make that work for the little dramas
i don't i think we're going to have in
big cities we're always going to have
those intellectual art house cinemas
but they will disappear from small towns
and we will see uh
big movie theaters and the comeback of
drive-ins chris i
i really believe uh
what covet has given us is the
appreciation of that drive-in experience
again
uh i i i do believe that mulan should be
seen on a big screen
drive-ins did good business over the
summer they weren't even not showing
new movies people were going to see
empire strikes back and raiders of the
lost ark and ghostbusters
uh just to get out of the house and go
see a movie on a big screen
and and what does that portend it
pretends to a
a communal experience that we're missing
we are
in uh a bunch of communities a bunch of
communities that thrive together and
what better way to come together than
entertainment
and movies just like sports bring us
together to to the field
the field of dreams so to speak um
so these it's not sustainable forever
these movie
movie theaters showing at 25 or 50
capacity their business plans
work on big sold out weekends
for the new big big movies and their
margins just aren't big enough
to sustain it for you know into
for two to too much longer at some point
things should get back to normal
when when the coronavirus thing is gone
but um they're gonna have to stay in
business until that happens
it's true they um
they're financially working that out i
spoke with uh
john fithian uh the president of the
nassau national association of theater
owners this past week
and this is something that they are
planning for in the future
they weren't necessarily ready for this
they know
that this may happen again they
understand their business model
and they are also
wedging that and using these past couple
weekends
and drive-ins and those finances
to make sure that if this does happen
again if this does continue
they will be okay until it comes back
full force
the mulan thing again i wonder as long
as this is still
in effect let's say the milan experiment
does well for disney
i wonder if over the next few months
maybe you see the new wonder woman movie
show up
on hbo max or another big movie or two
that's on the shelf show up on their
parent company streaming service just to
get that money back
now because these are 200 million dollar
movies that have been sitting on a shelf
if if theaters are open they will be in
theaters
it's just that experience
unless you have a 60-foot tv
and are having your neighbors over and
their kids
it's not going to work it really it
detracts from
what the filmmaker had imagined what i
do see
is is these movies landing at home
a little bit earlier maybe two weeks
sure what's going on with production
like i just said
there's a bunch of big movies that are
just sitting on shelves that were
supposed to come out this year that now
will wait until next year
what about the production end are movies
starting to be made
again movies are starting to be made
again
the producers guild of america last week
sent out a new set of safety protocols
i've spoken to many people that are on
sets
they have a dedicated person to make
sure
uh that they are being tested every hour
this is the way it's starting yeah and
they first of all they don't want any
lawsuits that's number one
number two um they have to get the
business going
and this is the safest way to do it
everybody
is is abiding by these because they
understand that if they don't get their
business up and running
they're not gonna get paid michelle
palino fox news
radio entertainment reporter michelle
thanks for uh for jumping on the fox
news rundown
well thank you
from the fox news podcasts network in
these ever-changing times
you can rely on fox news for hourly
updates for the very latest news and
information
on your time listen and download now at
foxnewspodcast.com or wherever you get
your favorite podcasts
subscribe to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com
and now some good news with tanya j
powers
[Music]
seven-year-old henry jones got a very
unique birthday
present this year thanks to his
neighbors and his community in tulsa
oklahoma
his mom carrie jones says henry who has
autism
loves billboards and each night his
family rides around
to look at them you have a kid with
autism it's
they're not always interested in things
a typical seven-year-old would be
interested in
so we just go with it we use whatever we
can to help him learn
in lieu of a traditional birthday party
this year she came up with a different
idea
and posted about it on facebook she
asked for contact information
for billboards the post blew up i just
wanted some contact information
i didn't i had no idea that people would
grab onto this the community responded
in just minutes with dozens of people
chiming in with ideas and well wishes
and lamar advertising offered to share
birthday messages for henry free of
charge
last weekend during his drive henry got
to see a big
green billboard reading happy birthday
henry jones we love you
more than you love billboards he hit his
face
which he does when he's excited and just
kept saying happy birthday henry jones
happy birthday henry jones
another sign company put a birthday
display in his front yard overnight
so now henry can see it anytime he wants
carrie says she was surprised by the
support from their community
and grateful for her special kid even
though he can't communicate with you
there's so much in there and he's so
smart and his interests are so odd but
we just go with it tanya trey powers fox
[Music]
news
it's time for your fox news commentary
tammy bruce
what's on your mind the nancy pelosi
salon scandal has been appropriately
receiving a lot of attention
on its face it is insulting an abuse of
power and a punch in the nose of all
americans who've obeyed covet 19
lockdown restrictions
at the expense of their quality of life
and in so many instances
their life's work but there she was in
broad daylight on a security camera
inside a closed salon in san francisco
waltzing along without a mask
her hair wet and in the presence of
salon staff
governor gavin newsom of california
remains under fire
for bizarre and arbitrary rules keeping
the economy of that state shut down
small business owners are being
destroyed as people are being driven
into poverty san francisco's politicians
as of september 1st
raised their scepter and declared salons
could open
for outdoor hair styling only they do
not allow hair coloring outside
because other restrictions ban certain
chemicals
from being introduced into the
environment the salon mrs pelosi was
visiting was shut to the general public
but was contacted by a freelance stylist
who rents a station in the salon
who said that mrs pelosi had contacted
them and was coming in
while this episode in and of itself is
worthy of outrage it is just one more
illustration
of how the ruling class believes that
they are above the law it's not just
insulting it's dangerous it shows that
politicians feel more than comfortable
issuing draconian grotesque and
dangerous laws
viewing american citizens as collateral
damage in their fun little game
an obsessive drive for power while mrs
pelosi flouts the law in her home city
as women who are not multi-millionaires
watch their hard work
and futures go down the drain we also
have philadelphia mayor
jim kenney who banned indoor dining in
that great american city due to covet
19.
he was then seen enjoying a lovely
indoor dining experience
in maryland philadelphians noticed
and are not happy this arrogant flouting
of what are supposed to be
existential laws and rules reveals
something especially urgent
these politicians are admitting with
their own behavior
that they don't believe those rules are
even necessary
the lockdown of small businesses
including restaurants is based on the
argument that it's a matter of life and
death
wear that mask or you're going to kill
grandma or
indoor dining can't happen because
you're going to die or you're going to
cause somebody else to die
and then the keep that salon or store or
gym or church closed because again
everyone's going to die
that lecture neither mrs pelosi or mr
kenny felt that they were in danger
by flouting laws and rules they force on
others in the name of the ubiquitous
safety we see this double standard on a
gigantic scale
with condemnation and scorn by
democratic politicians
of trump political gatherings while they
support and even encourage
left-wing political demonstrations and
riots
isn't it time we end this many are
observing that this hypocrisy
and the nonsensical nature of the
shutdown prove it is a political effort
to depress the economy
because it might hurt president trump
the daily caller reported
internal polling at the trump campaign
showing that likely voters still care
significantly more
about jobs and the economy than any
other issue heading into the 2020
election
no doubt the democrats have found the
same thing many have been perplexed at
the inexplicable decisions
by democrats keeping major american
cities like new york los angeles and san
francisco shut down
but by shutting down those economic
engines perhaps they imagine this will
harm trump
you they don't even think about their
hatred for mr trump is completely
consuming them
at our expense deliberate economic
destruction while allowing domestic
terrorism to continue
on a nightly basis in some great
american cities
tells us at the very least what they're
capable of
this is tammy bruce
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at foxnewspodcasts.com
and for up to the minute news
go to foxnews.com
[Music]
it's the latest from fox news podcasts
the campaign with bret bear with updates
from reporters on the trail and
in studio experts brett keeps you
informed on the 2020 race
go to foxnewspodcast.com and download
the campaign with brett bear
now love fox news click the subscribe
button to get more of the news and
opinion you trust
and click the fox news rundown playlist
for the latest episodes